two days beyond the very severe attack
of Russians yesterday on the confirmed
figures we have 84 Russian missiles and
43 were down by Ukrainian
anti-missiles forces and today again
dozens of Russian missiles go to the
civilian object of Ukraine including 10
in key of 12 in zaporizia and they was
launched from the Caspian Sea from
Belarusian territory and from ground
forces of Russia and it is extremely
important that only yesterday 23
ukrainians were killed all civilian no
single soldier and more than 100 were
wounded and this just happening in the
center of Kiev where I am now and we
yesterday just were absolutely confirmed
that Putin whole hopes to make a
Ukrainian a fate is absolutely collapsed
Ukraine start the more united and
Ukraine just prove that Ukrainian Nation
are unbreakable and it's uh just a fact
that under the seven and a half months
of the war pujin do not understand that
Ukrainian are the most unbreakable
nation and today 18 crew is missiles and
eight Kamikaze drone were down by
Ukrainian forces and with that situation
this is a interesting biggest Forbes
published that the total amount of money
which caused Russian missiles just for
one day yesterday cost more than 700
million dollars but at the same time
Russia received from energy expert more
than 900 million a day that's why all
the money from the Western payer for the
energy right putting spend on the bomb
and missiles against Ukrainian Putin
fighting not against Ukraine put in
fighting not against Ukrainian Armed
Forces we can fight and against
Ukrainian women Ukrainian children at
the end of the day against the whole
Democratic World against Freedom against
democracy and last day is just make a
provement that Putin is weak which is in
panic and those who call for the
compromise with Putin based on the
Ukrainian capitalization make a great
mistake Ukraine is fighting for our own
for All European freedom and democracy
what would you say the public mood is at
the moment because this is the first
time that this is a new wave of attacks
isn't it and I wonder if as as winter
starts to approach that there is a sort
of sense of gloom and doom setting in
amongst the general population
definitely not what Putin expects
just uh we have our volunteers formed
and there is several very big volunteers
upon there can you imagine that the
number of money Putin sorry a number of
money against Putin people sent to this
volunteer phone he increased to 20 times
and this is the right answer of
Ukrainian people we are decisive we are
unbreakable we are not be afraid of
Putin and Putin please do not expect
that Putin break Ukrainian ability to
protect our own land Ukrainian are ready
to fight and this fight would be until
our Victory together with the assistance
of our partnership Alliance and with
that situation I want to specially thank
the British people the British
Parliament bipartisan the British
government and Rich prime minister
because I just return from the
conference in the in Birmingham of the
conservative party have some meeting
with the labor party representative and
I am very much impressed with the
leadership of Britain in the global
world and today it is extremely
important that prime minister trust Liz
trust uh initiated the special
urgent uh online uh conference of NATO
how what would be the act of NATO member
states
followed by the Russian missile attack
and we definitely expect that this is
the time to act not to speak and this is
definitely we expect that Ukraine will
receive the new anti-missile and
anti-aircraft weapons and these weapons
can help us to protect Ukraine Ukrainian
uh sky and the second important events
within maybe half an hour or even 20 20
minutes in Brands the they will launch
the special G7 meeting where we have a
negotiation again how to support Ukraine
but that would be not supporting Ukraine
this is investment in the security of
the whole Europe and the whole native
member states of the whole world and
tomorrow we have a Ramstein meeting in
Brussels where participating our
minister of defense and that should be a
real anti-pouting Coalition with the
real acting Supply and the more weapons
Supply and the new technology Supply and
more assistance and demonstrate that
Putin simply do not have any tiny chance
to win the free Democratic world you're
talking about support I wonder what is
the public support uh for president
zielinski at the moment do you think
that he still has the backing of the
full Ukrainian population
we uh
I am not the leader of proposition
and zelinski is not the uh president all
of us are soldiers and we are united to
stop Russian aggression and this Unity
Unity of all Ukrainian surprise Putin
this is definitely not what he expected
and the unity of the whole world
together with the Britain U.S and other
member states is also the factor for our
uh for our Victory but the most
important thing that the
Ukrainian people support their armed
forces of Ukraine who is a real hero who
is the real Diplomat and who definitely
bring the Victory and I am proud that
since the year 2014 we
create the new Ukrainian Armed Forces
which now demonstrate their efficiency
and now all of us United around
Ukrainian Armed Forces including the
presidency without a compromise with
Putin why it's impossible because Putin
want to kill all of us
that's why he come here he want to erase
Ukraine from the world map
and we simply want to live
we simply want to believe and protect
our nation and our country and this is
just the the purpose of Putin is
demonstrating the story of yesterday
child uh mother of whom just leave them
in the kindergarten and go because she
was a doctor in the Oncology Clinic uh
in ahmadiat hospital and yesterday she
was killed by Russian results
and the Child live awful and this is the
how we understand the Putin action the
Putin cries and the Putin style
compromise in Ukraine with that
situation the only way how to stop the
world the only way how to stop the world
is to supply more weapons to Ukraine
because this is bring peace faster to
give us the full membership in NATO same
like European Union give us the status
of candidate in EU
the supply more and create the new
Marshall Plan for Ukraine and introduce
the new sanction and you embargo which
can limit Putin to finance that and the
more active the more professional we
will do that the faster would be peace